you always wanted to be a director
director since I was about 9 or 10 yeah
yeah and we did and when you got on
Saturday Night Live and you quit after
five weeks cuz you were like I don't
want to be in sketches and I don't want
to write jokes I want to just direct
stuff yeah I mean at that point I just
wanted to make short films and I knew
that I wasn't good live because I would
get nervous but Lauren hired you I had
made a short film that I sold to
Saturday Night Live earlier that was a
take-off on the color of money it's
brought up to Lorne to show you figured
hey I'll join Saturday alive I'll do
like an Albert Brooks thing where I can
just reduce little short films for them
right that would have been an
interesting thing yeah and yeah and
that's really what was what I wanted to
do but I just felt I was I just felt I
couldn't do well in that situation that
was why who was there when you were
there as Lovitz and Dennis Miller you
know Laura Dunn and you know I picture
like a guy like Dennis Miller being so
quick with comedy that's like if you're
sitting in a room with them and you're
not coming up with something witty every
five minutes you ready to hang yourself
yeah yes and it's very you know and they
were the big boys there and you know and
there was it was very competitive and do
some of these comedians like guys on
Saturday live who were established like
Dennis Miller love it's all these guys
do they kind of also have a chip on
their shoulder toward you because you
grew up in a showbiz family do they go
hey prove yourself you're not like us
huh I don't know you know it depending
on I mean Jon Lovitz literally I was
doing a play where I had a really small
part but the play was very successful
right and when when I made that little
short film and Lovitz came to see the
play and that's how I reached out to him
about bringing this little movie this
short I made up to Saturday live like he
literally he was abortive yeah he did me
a favor and brought it up to to Lorne
when you showed up just this past season
as Michael Cohen Donald Trump's guy you
know the lawyer is your name Michael
Cohen yes and you're a lawyer
ish I was surprised to see you on there
like how do you suddenly show up on a
sketch it was weird I
I actually had emailed Lorne about
wanting to take my daughter to the show
my daughter's 16 and she never been to
Saturn alive and I want I said hey let's
go what does she want to be in she want
to be an actress she does yeah why they
okay and when you say you want to go to
the show are you gonna sit in the
audience or are you gonna take her
backstage I can kind of like hang it to
hang out backstage I can hang out in the
greenroom you know you can be a good
father
well yeah I mean it's like you know one
of those things that you can take
advantage of like I'd let you know
anything to impress my daughter father
than I'll take advantage of whatever he
do and and so anybody sent him the email
and then he sent me back an email the
next day saying sure sounds fun great
and oh by the way do you happen to have
a Michael Cohen
impression lying around oh wow yeah but
in his inimitable lorne style